uh another thing is that uh we we get
mosquitoes here in japan we don't
yeah we do oh yeah yes
are you do you not get bitten no
lucky i never get that much how would
you not get [ __ ] i get eaten alive
maybe my blood doesn't taste good i
don't know i've never had a mosquito
apparently it does depend on your blood
type okay i think it does because i get
bitten to [ __ ] whenever mosquitoes don't
go for me i know i can be in an area
where someone will get bitten a ton i
won't have any on me i literally like
god always tells me yeah i literally
laid outside on my balcony for like half
an hour came inside and i had like 10
bites on my back
i'm not even joking yeah i'm exactly the
same i don't get by but i yeah i've
never even
i don't even know they had them here
yeah because normally normally they're
very good jamie i don't get bitten are
you serious serious
i thought they didn't have them here
because that's the that's another reason
i love british summers is that we don't
we just don't have any bugs that are
annoying because well you guys don't
have mosquitoes no
do you not remember when we were just
chilling out in england in my garden i
just thought i got lucky
[Laughter]
i just thought like oh there's a
stronger there's a stronger blood type
somewhere in the vicinity that they're
going there's no mosquitoes no i'm just
that guy because like i'm just that guy
who like
i'm i'm the bait right because is that
meme of like the blades falling down and
the guy covering yeah
everyone else everyone else at the party
yeah because like if people hang out
with me in thailand or japan or whatever
they get bitten less because i'm there
i'm the bait i i am what every mosquito
goes towards and i don't know why
because tomato
because in thailand we have we have this
saying where um normally it's the
mosquitoes go for the foreign people
because it's the foreign people who have
the sweet blood because the mosquitoes
aren't used to their blood so that was
but it's it's so that was the [ __ ]
life well technically i didn't grow up
in thailand so maybe there's some kind
of truth to it but apparently apparently
if you have never been beat if
mosquitoes are beaten by mosquitoes
[ __ ] you know what's going on huh
coming to our neighborhood
i've never i've never get bitten by
mosquitoes i'm so [ __ ] dude is it
like a blood type thing i don't even
know apparently it's like a blood type
thing it's also like a skin thing as
well like certain skin like if you have
like oily skin you're more likely to get
bitten like that i don't know there's
lots of theories out there i i think
it's literally just like
if you're unlucky or unlucky kind of
thing yeah pretty much beer
oh yeah no apparently if you're you get
uh you're more likely to get stung if
you're drunk
is that true yeah apparently i make the
mosquitoes drunk
i don't know that's probably why they're
like um guys come time for a sesh right
because i get drunk in the blood right
baby
drinking so i don't know what's going on
is there a reason why mosquitoes go for
people more or less yes
there's like seven reasons yeah why but
i don't know if any of that has actually
been like scientifically confirmed i
feel it's just like it might be like a
lot of like coincidences it's not tasty
enough what the [ __ ] like what are they
like tasting
as well that's probably good
tasty bro what i want to be tasty
you don't want to be tasty you don't
want to be tasty missing out i want to
be tasty that's [ __ ] mosquitoes are
[ __ ] they're the worst they're the
[ __ ] [ __ ] for the [ __ ] insects
nobody likes mosquitoes people they
could be like the biggest animal lover
in the world and they see a mosquito and
like [ __ ] that little [ __ ] isn't like
the mosquito i think i read somewhere
isn't the mosquito like the only animal
in like the food chain where if you got
rid of them it just wouldn't change the
food chain
i don't know if that's an urban legend
but i hope it's true i think it's
something like that because i remember
saying because like i think i looked it
up because i was like because in
australia we have a [ __ ] ton of flies
yeah yeah during the summer right like
it's [ __ ] horrible especially if
you're like out in the desert yeah
nothing but flies it's disgusting and i
think i just thought to myself like man
i really just wish all flies just
disappeared and then one of my friends
was like oh no like flies are like
really important to the food chain yeah
like there's a lot of animals that eat
flies and i thought like yeah is there
an animal where if we just
it just disappeared one day
would the would the food change still be
intact and i think mosquitoes was one of
those humans probably oh yeah
i i think i think they'd be grateful
actually
[Laughter]
i mean i hope mosquitoes are [ __ ]
useless things because i mean they just
[ __ ] carry diseases right like that's
all they really do yeah they all they do
is like give malaria to people right for
anybody there's probably like other
things there's probably one like really
obscure species of spider or something
that could only feed on mosquitoes that
would die out that's like integral
it's always like that like no no this is
one animal that specifically eats this
thing yeah how would you even eradicate
mosquitoes i would even go about that
i don't know i don't ask the aussie they
[ __ ] they've they've had like enough
problems trying to eradicate a certain
yeah
like